hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday step stream
recap day like always we have lots of
news to talk about like a new event
possibly coming soon within the next
week at the start of season six as well
as a roadmap for the first month of
season six and patch 1.23 summary and a
lot of other stuff to talk about but
really quick though I'm going to be
having a live stream this Saturday I
like to do it every single Saturday but
this Saturday around 1 to 2 p.m. est I'm
gonna be streaming so definitely check
around the channel for that if you want
to come by chill out gel with everybody
in the stream talk to me if you have a
question about anything I'll gladly
answer it during the stream so like I
said stop by if you want to and with
that guys like the view if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the
leaks the informational the patch notes
the balance changes the new events all
that good stuff the informational side
of foreigner I like to cover and let's
get started with the news today one
really quick tidbit of info though today
is May 10 so that means the new
executions have released today's to
definitely help on foreigner and by the
one for your specific hero if you have
no clue what I'm talking about go to my
video last week and you'll see the new
executions there'll be a timestamp all
that good [ __ ] but first things first is
the road map in it I'll show a picture
on screen so you guys understand what
I'm looking at but first up is May 17th
it's the release date of season 6 and it
comes to everything we talked about last
week which is the Orochi and peacekeeper
reworks the beachhead map the revamp
champagne status and the visual
collection if you haven't seen any of
that like I said click the I on the top
right and you'll be taken in my video
about this from last week and then we
also have timestamps in the video just
in case you need specific info on
something for example if you know about
the reworks but not about the new visual
collection this is a timestamp in the
description of that video you could be
taken to as well season 6 will also
release with a new special seasonal
event the day it releases on May 17th
and a new order called Belle Volvo
Medusa
there are similar variations of this
event order coming in the later weeks
called musashi the crane and he jerks
the war hog I'm pretty sure I butchered
those names but regardless my guess is
that these are tied to the new event
because if you look at the images
they're the same ones in the background
of the special season 6 event tab in the
bottom left of the picture as from what
they are specifically we have no clue
yet but the developer said that there'll
be tons of new info on this new event
next week so stay tuned on the channels
to subscribe as well next week for the
recap of the event and what's in store I
cannot wait for this to see what's going
to happen
besides that though on the new roadmap
we're also going to be getting a new
event playlist where you can play
Dominion on the new beachhead map and
only the new beachhead map which like I
said we talked about last week and a new
XP fest coming from June 11th and going
the whole week through June 18th so if
you have a new character you want to
wrap up or you're trying to get your guy
to rep 50 like I am then that's a
perfect time to play since it's an
entire week as well III will be around
that time any for honor devs we'll be
showing off some new goodies they have
in store for us whether that be new
modes new heroes new maps etc it will
all be III so don't worry I will gladly
share all the info with you that they
talked about as for what it is like I
said we have no clue but it's probably
going to be some new stuff and hopefully
some really interesting things they get
a lot more people back into the game
as for the road map let me let me know
what you guys think about this new
seasonal event or possibly what it could
be I want to know any of your thoughts
that'd be really nice to know in the
comments below let's start a discussion
about that next up we have the new
community event and that's called
warriors rush and is be the first
faction to complete the highest amount
of matches of any type basically just
play any match in the first faction to
get it will win it steel and crates they
did talk about the rewards the first
place team will get 1500 steel and three
crates so definitely go in there and try
to be the first faction to win it it's
gonna be all weekend and of course you
have to participate in order to get to
these rewards next up is the tournament
rewards for season 6 season 6 has
introduced new ornaments for the winners
of tournaments aka the legendary reward
tier as seen on screen now you can only
get the hero ornament for the hero that
you play so if I win the tournament as
Highlander I will get the highlander
ornament if i already have the
highlander ornament in my loadout art i
will get a different hero's ornament as
well i wish it wasn't the same ornament
as opposed to last season where we each
got different ornaments depending on the
hero but still regardless is a real cool
nice ornament tier 2 or the hero rewards
here which is roughly when your about
second place if you're playing the duel
tournament is a faction based engraving
you get a specific engraving from the
hero you play for example if I play
Reiter he's a Viking and I get second
place I will get the Viking embossing or
engraving and same goes for the other
factions as well you're also going to be
getting a color swatch and this is for
all factions so it doesn't matter the
faction of the character only the
character that you play in the
tournament itself next up is tier 3 also
known as the versatile tier and you're
gonna be eating some standard faction
based emblems and some
nothing too great but they're still cool
nonetheless so if you do want to get
those definitely try to get that third
place but to continue on some of the
changes in season six include that you
can't get rewards from previous seasons
anymore
they have been taken out so if you
haven't gotten the season three four
five all that stuff that's already gone
I luckily got these season five stuff so
I don't have to do that anymore so I'm
definitely gonna try to get these season
six award and as well there's going to
be a guaranteed chance of getting lower
tiers so you don't need to throw the
final match to get that Tier two reward
one of the issues people are having is
that some people like the tier 2 reward
but didn't want to throw the last match
because they might as well win it
because then they might get an ornament
for a hero they played but they had to
throw it because they wanted to get the
tier 2 reward now that doesn't matter
anymore so you can get those tier 2
rewards or tier 3 rewards without having
to purposely lose a match just to get
them the dev's also showed off the
reputation rewards for 40 and 50 the
ornament you get is that rep 40 in is
called the seal of mastery I'm fairly
certain this is going to be the same
ornament for all heroes I wish they had
different ornaments per hero but still
it's a cool ornament nonetheless next up
is the outfit route for rep 15 now this
is only on the warden in the screenshot
so it may look better or worse depending
on the specific hero you pick and then
the new outline for your emblem once you
hit rep 50 with any character in for
honor these words are alright but I'm
thinking I was thinking something more
flashy to signify to everyone in the
game that you're a rep 50 and that you
granted your ass off for that rep and
then lastly for the video we have the
new patch 1.2 3 now most of the info and
patch 1.2 3 was talked about last week
like I've stated numerous times in this
video if you need a refresher on what it
is or haven't seen it yet check my video
from last week to get all caught up on
all the juicy info we talked about last
week but some of the new stuff in this
patch includes for example we have a new
level of refinement and that is called
Pro find two new pieces of gear can drop
that can be refined two times as opposed
to last season where we got refined gear
once you can only refine it one time
we're fine two gear have a chance to
drop whenever you loot a legendary gear
for a hero rep 10 or higher and the
chances of getting a refined two gear
increase with a rep level so you have a
higher chance of getting refined two
gear for my rep 30 character as opposed
to a rep 10 that is just starting to get
that type of gear we're fine to crafting
worse the same as the single refine
crafting except that you can do it
more than once and previous refined gear
cannot be upgraded to refine - you're
going to have to beginning all new gear
entirely which is kind of suck so you
might as well just throw out the refine
one gear out the window once you get the
refine to because there's basically no
point for it refine a bull gear does not
affect the gear score so the gear score
cap is not affected whatsoever
and you can tell once you've fully
upgraded the refine to gear because it
is displayed as two diamonds above the
gear icon and when you have an entire
full set of refined to gear the two
diamonds will be displayed over your
hero's overall gear score you may have
seen that in some of the games when you
fight certain heroes and maybe like a
Dominion game I don't see it too often
because not many people really care for
the refinement well hopefully what
they're refined to people might actually
start using this and care a lot more and
then lastly for the patch that is new is
that the event gear that we've been
getting from the Halloween event the
Christmas event and then the most recent
test your mettle of it and then probably
this new seasonal event we're getting
next week with it's now going to have a
distinctive event icon probably from the
event itself to identify the name of
course so that you don't get caught up
in all of the loadout stuff that's
happening within your character
thankfully this was added cuz one of the
issues that you have like 30 types of
gear there's so much stuff that you have
to remember like okay that's part of the
seasonal event I can't get rid of that
and then there is no like a lock button
or any of that stuff so it's just this
huge headache and luckily they added
this so now you don't accidentally
delete something that's only a seasonal
thing and then you can't get it for a
very long time there is also some minor
bug fixes well in this patch I won't go
into detail what they are but if you do
want to check them out for yourself
there's a link in the description and
you'll be taken right to it to see for
yourself and with that guys that's going
to be the end of the video today I want
to start something new that I did in my
past videos I didn't get to do it last
week because I forgot but something I
like to do I'm gonna be calling it the
question of the day we're gonna be
starting a discussion in the comments
below with this question that I'm gonna
be talking about roughly related to the
news we mentioned every week and the
question of the day is going to be what
do you guys think about the new event
what do you think is going to be in it
is it player versus player similar to
the Halloween and Christmas event or is
this more of a tester metal mode where
it's PvE I think it's more of a PvE tip
because of the characters names like
Belleville Medusa Heydrich the war hog
they sound like bosses that we get to
fight against so I'm assuming it's gonna
be a PvE event tell me anything you guys
think it's going to be in it I love
your thoughts in the comments below but
like the V if you do enjoy it really
does help me out subscribe if you're new
I covered the leaks the informational
sign up for honor the balance patch
notes the new events the hero updates
the balances like I said the patch notes
everything the informational side of for
honor I like to cover my two most recent
videos going to be on screen if you guys
want to check that out I highly
recommend you do if you haven't and with
that guys hope have a great rest your
day and peace out